I am here to conquer my fear of heights
by going down a gigantic waterslide I
don't like going more than like like
three stories high I have a fear of
heights and also water slides I've never
written a waterslide I got to face this
fear because I have a six-year-old son
and he's getting old enough to the point
where he can ride the big kid rides at
theme park so I need to overcome this so
I can go enjoy rides with them kind of
scared nervous can we start with
something easier than this so I'm
sitting behind Rob on the aqua coaster
and I'm wondering who's doing all of
this screaming I don't know if you call
it a shrill that comes out from deep
inside and you can hear is yelled from a
mile away
I think this is a fun distraction from
what we're really doing here that's not
like preparing me for it it made it
worse
actually this is crazy
okay that's not at all pthey and called
the body plunge so the floor just gives
way
[Music]
all right I gotta get the jitter now
[Music]
I went first that was more than what I
could have expected that was too much
you've no idea how much I was shaking
the view everything about it was
terrifying
I think I was the most scared to be
honest with you out of everybody more
scary than I thought
way more scary than I thought nope that
weightlessness with the nuts I feel like
I could do it again
the whole process and talking through it
with each other and egging each other on
we funded I think I did what I came to
do I faced my fear of heights
bring it on world I'm glad I did it I'm
glad I conquered it and I'm good though
I'm not gonna skydive or anything it's a
liberating feeling to know that I won't
be the most scared person going down a
ride that my son will be a little bit
more scared and he can look to me and I
go no it'll be okay
[Music]